Oh sup guys my name is China welcome
back to my game into the series so last
time we took a look at improving how
render a 2-d a bit adding statistics so
that we could see how long everything
takes check out that video if you
haven't already and today I thought that
we would do something a little bit
different what we're gonna do today is
take a look at a game that someone has
made and we're going to both take a look
at it in terms of like a stress test for
a bat renderer but also just in general
to see how someone goes about making a
game in hazel someone from the community
which is really really cool
so you might remember from the last
episode I asked you guys to come up with
some kind of stress test for the batch
render or basically just some kind of
test case scenario something that we
could use to actually assess the
performance and the scalability I guess
of our new batch renderer so someone
called 0x has gone ahead and made a
clone of this eddie's game called
balderdash in hazel and gone ahead and
posted it to the game engine series
channel on discord and with his
permission with his or her permission
we're gonna go ahead and actually both
look at it and use it as a test case for
Hazel's performance and even though it's
not particularly like a very very very
heavy stress test or something that's
designed to absolutely use every feature
I still think it's a really good
indication of the general performance of
the engine and the way that this started
was just with like a simple balderdash
clone that was you know not much of
really a stress test because again when
you're remaking an a DS game usually
it's not gonna stress it's not gonna
stress out modern hardware or a modern
engine but then 0x or ox maybe we'll
just call me we'll just call them ox
from now on zero zero ox has gone ahead
and I ox is it's definitely not ox zero
X's like at the beginning of like
hexadecimal string but anyway whatever
so 0x has gone ahead and actually kind
of just expanded the level and turned it
into a stress test
I just got I've been talking with him on
discord and that's what's happened so
first of all if you guys are not on
discord you're missing out link in
description below the journal I'm such
discord this is all happening in the
game engine series channel if you're
quick you can just scroll up and you can
see all of this taking place you can
just you know read that conversation and
all of that stuff and in fact look at
that your 0x is posting right now that
hazel 2d is already my favorite engine
so that's nice I don't know if that's
sarcasm because there is a week
face but we'll just take it as it is and
the thing that I love about this
particular example is it's not just a
graphics stress test this is like the
whole game it's it's a clone of the game
so this is like you know I mean there's
animation there's game logic there's
kind of there's all this stuff happening
there's even a little bit of like 80s
style physics all of this stuff is
actually happening in this application I
think that's obviously a much better
test than just like you know hey let's
draw as many causes that we can with no
real logic no real gameplay nothing like
that that stops boring so I really like
this thank you to 0x of course for
making this clone and I will of course
leave a link in the description below
through the github repository that
contains this balderdash clone so if you
want to take a look and play this for
yourself and just take a look at it then
you can of course do that ok enough
talking let's jump in and take a look at
this balderdash clone and take a look at
Hazel's performance
okay so launching this this is what we
get so where this little player here you
can see there's a bunch of animators
Bryce we've got a fair few quads and
textures and stuff like that on the
screen let's go through this and try and
play it we can use the WASD keys here we
have these diamonds we can collect I'm
running this in release mode by the way
just so that we can get an accurate
performance kind of reading and the
camera moves and we have these boulders
crashing all in all I think it's a
really cool little game demo thing let's
go here collect this I really should be
going a lot faster I don't know why I'm
taking my time I have to be honest with
you guys as someone who's relatively
young I have not played the original at
all so I I yeah this is completely just
this is what's the word I'm looking for
embarrassing ok I just died that's
embarrassing almost pretty that pretty
to that alright lets quickly try and get
through this and we'll try and get into
the second level so I can show you guys
what that looks like if you're quick
enough I did look up some videos of the
original derp and I have to say that I
think the original is a lot faster you
can move a lot faster which probably
makes it easier but then again maybe I
just saw some weird video who knows
let's just run past this let's get this
again I'm going very slowly here let's
see if I can just accelerate a little
bit alright let's go over here
alright get this I'm kind of worried
about this because of course this could
all crumble just by chance because there
is a mechanic that I learned about we're
in this game and I didn't know this
because of course I haven't played the
original where you can just you can just
die because oh no I'm kind of stuck okay
I made it okay let's go this way
all right we're on level two you can
just die because every like you can just
randomly this stuff can randomly
collapse on you so that's a bit bad like
that was just dumb alright as scary
starts it let's get the diamond and
let's go over here anyway you guys get
the coin I'm not gonna this isn't like a
let's play but but if it was let's kind
of hide here I'm dead on I can't do
anything alright that's done I was gonna
show you guys this enemy but it seems
that I can't oh we can push boulders I
did not know that
alright this thing kills you as well as
you can see okay that's the idea let's
take a little bit of a look at the
performance so if I just select one of
these things here so that we pause the
console you can see that the performance
is pretty good like interlaced mode
we're getting around it
I mean it's quite sporadic because you
know of course at this at this low of a
millisecond count the framerate is gonna
jump a lot even though we might only be
like half a millisecond slower in a
certain frame than another frame but you
can see generally like wait we're around
2000 FPS half a millisecond I'd say is a
pretty good average here we're getting a
lot of frames that are a lot faster than
that
performance is great and we can't really
easily compare this to what it was like
with the old renderer because well we
deleted the old renderer and it also
uses a slightly different API but I'm
sure it would have been probably a
little bit slower I mean again there are
not that many tiles going on here there
are not that many quads so the draw
calls aren't going to be slowing this
down too much I think however this is
where the fun stress test comes in so if
we take a look at this stress test this
is a much larger level you can see here
is level it's just defined as a string
here if we launch this and you can see
here that I'm launching it in debug I
just want to show you guys what debug
looks like because I think that it's an
important distinction to make here so
this is debug you can see this level is
huge you can see our frame time is quite
terrible 6 frames per second
it's running very very slowly you can
see the renderer 2d statistics here so
I've actually split this up into three
draw calls I was just playing around
with this before if we jump into
renderer 2d we can set that back to like
20,000 because I just lowered this to
5000 max quads just so we could see if
splitting it up into draw calls would
make it any faster but anyway you can
see that we're running at about 6 frames
per second here it's really not that
great
that's what debug mode looks like but we
do have this nice big beautiful level
now the problem is it's because we're
running in debug mode so if we change
this to release mode and now we run it
it's going to be a lot faster so this is
running in release mode with iron GUI
and you can see that first of all
instead of 6 frames per second we're in
like a hundred and 70 or so right our
frame time is like around 5 to 7
milliseconds it's super fast but that's
again that's with I am GUI
I am GUI is actually taking about half
of our frame time if I I made a little
preprocessor macro here that I can just
use so if I actually turn off I am GUI
by removing it and we recompile our code
and we rerun our code you'll see it's
going to be a lot faster so these are
just generally important things I think
that you should take into consideration
when you try and test the performance of
hazel 100% make sure you were running in
release mode debug mode tests especially
with the amount of geometry that you're
trying to render if you are trying to
render like over 5000 or maybe even over
10,000 quads on the screen at once it's
really gonna slow down in debug mode and
we'll talk about why in just a minute
but make sure you're running in release
mode that's step one and step two is you
have to but disabling i''m GUI will
definitely boost the performance and I
am GUI really is not a great indication
because we're not going to be using I'm
GUI ever for distribution builds of
hazel I am GUI is only ever going to be
used for tools and debugging that kind
of stuff in hazel is going to use i''m
GUI that's why we have I am GUI well for
now it's useful for just debugging and
like quickly like adding buttons and
sliders and stuff like that to the
screen so we can manipulate variables
but in the future like in hazel dev for
example I'll show it on the screen now
we have a whole we have a whole level
editor and that whole kind of well it's
more of like a model of your at the
moment but that whole tool is built
using I am GUI and that's my kind of
strategy for UI
for tools but for runtime we are going
to write our own UI library we are going
to have our own like text rendering and
all of that stuff so I'm go is kind of a
temporary solution that you can use if
you want UI in hazel right now but in
the future that's going to change and
hopefully we're gonna write something
that's gonna be a lot faster than I'm
GUI for the actual runtime UI that we
end up doing but in general UI
unfortunately does tend to be a little
bit slower in game engines okay so now
this is compiled if we run it now you'll
see that the frame rate the frame time
is now down to about three or so
milliseconds we've even got some 2.8
here 300 frames per second seems to be
about the normal here it's a lot faster
without I'm GUI that's kind of the point
unless maximizes and take a look so
here's the player in the top left corner
everything is very tiny we're actually
rendering around 13,000 quads in this so
it's again not an amazing stress test
it's not like a hundred thousand we
could definitely squeeze a lot more out
of this it is running extremely fast
through 2.8 2.9 you know three
milliseconds per frame you can just
ignore that for that you know it's
running very very quickly and like the
FPS might seem lower like 300 versus
2000 but remember FPS is not like a
linear scale whereas this ears so you
should always look at milliseconds
instead because one millisecond slower
is gonna end up being a lot more than
like you know one unit let's just say
less FPS like it's not a great
comparison because X FPS tread tends to
like exponentially get larger when you
get you know a little bit lower towards
lower end of the millisecond frame times
so yeah take a look at that that's
important all right so and you can see
there's animations going this game logic
going like it's it's cool and you know
this one chasing meteor we've got the
hazel logo here which is super cool we
have a little bit of a hazel stress test
which is gonna be nice now I want to
quickly talk about why it's so slow in
debug mode because I know that that's a
question that a lot of people gonna have
why exactly is it running so slowly in
debug mode well long story short it's
all the maths that we're doing so we're
using GLM for mathematics and if you run
GLM in debug mode it's well I care I
haven't tested this but my very strong
suspicion is that it's not using any
kind of any kind of sim D rise single
instruction multiple
so what that means is like SSA and all
those kind of cpu ins extensions that
exist to actually use more than just
your general kind of 32-bit floats so
you cannot basically end up packing
packing a bunch of data packing like
four floats four 32-bit floats into a
128-bit wide register for example and
then actually multiplying them together
we're not gonna talk about SSE now I
just thought I'd give a general
definition of what it actually is for
those who have never heard of it
basically it is a cpu extension we'll
call it that lets you perform operations
on multiple pieces of data with a single
instruction hence the name single
instruction multiple data so what that
means is instead of multiplying four
floats with each other individually you
can actually pack them into a 128-bit
wide register well two sets of them and
then multiply them with one CPU
instruction and it basically just makes
everything a lot faster long story short
it basically makes your maths
potentially four times faster it's not
necessarily but potentially four times
faster so it's very very good now
without any kind of optimization maths
simple maths like just multiplication
and addition really falls apart really
falls apart so if we jump back into here
we are now in debug mode if I run this
in debug mode and this is how I can
prove my theory it's not really a theory
but we'll prove it anyway just so that
you guys are aware and just cuz I
thought this would be a good kind of
test case you can see we are getting 150
milliseconds per frame ridiculous so if
we profile this so we'll go debug
performance profiler CPU usage now note
the visual she is actually telling us
that we're in debug mode so we should
switch to release for more accurate
results but will will will still profile
it indeed in debug mode it is still
useful to profile things in debug mode
by the weight because you can see like
what exactly is the problem in debug
mode and what the slow parts are in
debug mode and also like a lot of the
time it's very desirable to optimize
debug mode because something like this
is very difficult to test but you still
might want all of your asserts and all
of your debug mode stuff alright we'll
stop that we'll look at this and if we
double click on let's double click on
maybe bold a layer on update then we're
taking to the code
we can actually see in red all the hot
parts you can see that by far 64 percent
of our time here is inside draw quad
okay so this is very red it's very is a
very hot path meaning that it takes up a
lot of time if we click on it over here
to go into it and see what the problem
is you'll see that well the biggest
problem here is this kind of just this
multiplication operator and we can see
up here GLM operator multiplied so this
kind of operator here is taking up the
most time by far so this is something
that really really fades away in release
mode and the reason for that is because
our compiler is able to optimize that
code it's able to use SSE in
vectorization and it's able to well
among other things like a faster
floating-point model we're not going to
get into like deep kind of optimizations
but the point is in release mode maths
becomes a lot faster and that's
obviously very important because we are
doing a lot of math over half of our
time here is spent just adding numbers
together that is why this stuff is
slower if we were a little bit more like
cache coherent maybe this would be
faster because we are kind of skipping
where we're not exactly completely as
like you know CPU cache packed together
as we could be for example the texture
index is all the same for a lot of these
it's hiring factors all the same the
texture coordinates are all the same you
know the colors are all the same but
we're still kind of having to process
all that data and retrieve more and more
memory and when you scale it up to like
over 10,000 quarts that can also slow it
down so I'm sure if we rearranged the
kind of the packing order and like we'll
rearrange the memory layout of all of
this so that our positions were all like
let's say all in a row meaning that when
we had to write to position we could
just kind of do that easily then we this
will probably be a lot faster this
particular stage but of course OpenGL
does need everything to be interleaved
we can't we can pack like positions say
into a separate vertex buffer and do
that that is actually possible I haven't
tried that I've actually just thought of
that now we can try that if someone
wants to try that go ahead post it in
discord and I'll take a look at it but
you know we are kind of limited by it by
a few things here
the moral of the story is superfast
maths release mode that's why it's
important to profile stuff in a release
mode and in fact as a little test let's
go ahead and jump in to release a launch
release and make sure it's running it is
running what I really meant to do was
actually go into debug performance
profiler and we're gonna profile this in
release mode just to see where the
bottleneck is in release mode so let's
let it run for a little bit maybe we'll
move around a bit and we'll hit stop
collection here and let's take a look at
what this looks like okay so what do we
have here application run on update so
application run itself is like you know
not taking up that much time I mean it's
60 something hazel on update I mean look
it still is draw quad like this is still
kind of the bottleneck and this is now
where it's like making me think that
maybe it is more or less to do with our
memory layout and that's probably the
next thing I would maybe look at
optimizing we have this kind of 11% so
this kind of transform matrix because we
are doing a bunch of matrix multiplies
here well we're doing one measures
multiply to be fair but that's kind of
the biggest thing I think that's going
on here so this stuff isn't really that
bad we have a for loop here that goes
through all of this and that's not too
bad I think but yeah this kind of
transform is is a little bit of a
problem and that's where I said I think
last episode that what you could do is
since we're not drawing rotated quads at
all we don't have to do a matrix
transform model like we don't have to do
a matrix multiplication here and create
a bunch of matrices like it's a little
bit of a waste because or if we if all
we want is position and scale we don't
need matrices at all we can just bake
that data immediately into the vertices
for our for our quad without actually
ever touching matrices we can just you
know multiply or add to workout scales
and position offsets and all of that
stuff so switching to that would
probably make us faster this is just
thoughts I'm giving out I'm not going to
go into this and attempt to make it
faster I don't think it's really that
necessary like part of me wants true
the other part of me thinks that like
maybe when we actually get to the point
where this is an issue where someone
actually makes a game and it you know it
really does need an optimization they
can either optimize it themselves or I
can think about actually getting it into
hazel and I might play around with this
but just in general I'm still happy with
the code I'm still happy with the
performance the way it is it would be
better it would be really good to get
better debug performance and I might
look into that maybe we can compile well
the GLM related code in like some kind
of optimized format even in debug mode
because it's not like we need to debug
that so we might enable like you know
vectorization as I say that stuff for
debug that would probably speed stuff up
as well as like you know inline
functions and all that stuff but anyway
that's pretty much all I wanted to talk
about today let me know what you guys
thought of this episode it was a little
something a little bit different looking
at what you guys have made in the
community is always so much fun to me
and it makes me so happy to see people
using hazel we are going to like with
all this in mind I think we can proceed
with whatever we're going to proceed
with whenever I look at stuff that the
people have made as well maybe it's
worth me actually diving into the
codebase and taking a look at how this
person has used hazel to make this I
think I will do that if you guys want to
see that in a video let me know in the
comments below and I'll make a video
just to meet looking at this card and in
fact I'm not even gonna look at the card
until I see whether in fact I'll make a
poll there'll be a poll up here do you
guys want to see a video of me going
through this card and taking a look at
it or would you rather just continue on
and hurry up and get to the next episode
of hazel let me know I'll leave a poll
up there make sure that you vote and if
I do do that I think I won't even take a
look at the code before that video so
you guys can see me kind of my real
thought process of looking at it for the
first time and what my thoughts are on
that anyway thank you guys so much for
watching patron or come for such
tutoring the best way to help support
this series and my channel and
everything that I do here live streams
are the best thing I think I'm doing on
patreon right now there's one tomorrow
morning so in fact I've been streaming
pretty much every Friday morning I
finally gotten better internet at home
so now my upload speed is like fantastic
and I can stream in like really good
quality so I'm super excited about that
the first stream with the new Internet
is happening tomorrow morning as I
mentioned so check that out if
you're interested you'll see me working
on a hazel dev and I think I'm going to
be implementing well fairly soon I'm
going to be implementing in ECS I'm
gonna be in implementing Lua I'm going
to be improving the graphics with like
ambient occlusion and all of that fun
stuff and doing shadow mapping soon if
you're interested in that then
definitely head on over to patreon help
support the series you'll get access to
the source code of what I'm writing as
well as all of these live streams so I
think it's a really cool way to help
support the community and help support
me and everything I love you guys and I
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]